Caching runs the full network every N
steps.
In between, it predicts the missing
features from history.
Existing methods apply one prediction rule
to the whole feature.
But is one rule enough for every part of a
feature?
Follow a single feature across the
denoising trajectory.
Some dimensions jump around, and they are
hard to predict.
Others change smoothly, almost linearly.
And some curve gently, so higher-order
prediction helps.
These behaviours are mixed together inside
the same vector.
One prediction order cannot match all of
them.
Could we just split the vector into
blocks?
A contiguous split puts smooth and
unstable dimensions in the same group.
Can we learn a representation that groups
them by behaviour?
LinCa learns an invertible mapping of the
cached feature.
It rearranges the dimensions into three
groups.
The first group collects the unstable
dimensions.
The second collects those that evolve
smoothly.
The third collects the gently curved ones.
Three groups is the design choice used in
the paper.
Each group now gets a predictor that fits
it.
The unstable group is simply reused from
the nearest cache.
The smoother groups use Hermite
extrapolation at matched order.
Then the inverse mapping reconstructs the
full feature.
Same feature, different subspaces,
different rules.
Why must the mapping be invertible?
So the decomposition itself loses no
information.
Each block mixes channels and couples two
halves.
One half updates the other, and then the
roles swap.
Every step has an explicit inverse.
The prediction can still be wrong; only
the mapping is exact.
The denoising trajectory is also split
into stages.
Each stage trains its own copy of the
predictor.
That is separate from the subspace
decomposition.
Training uses a few hundred pre-generated
features.
One loss matches the feature; another
matches each component.
Decompose, predict, reconstruct: that is
LinCa.